OK, here's a thought to start us
off.
What if mass deportations aren't
primarily about border security
or, you know, national
sovereignty or even public
safety?
What if it's actually about
money?
What if it's shaping up to be
America's next big economic
engine?
But it's quite.
A hook.
It is.
And today we're diving deep into
a concept that one writer, Chris
Abraham, provocatively calls the
Gold Rush of deportation right.
Our source for this deep dive is
Abrahams article titled
Deportation Gold Rush, America's
Next Bottomless War Economy,
published just recently, July
20, 2025.
Very current.
Exactly.
So our mission today is to
really unpack this, this pretty
bold claim.
We want to look at how Abraham
frames deportation as this major
economic force and, well, what
the real world implications
might be according to his
analysis.
OK, OK, let's let's unpack this,
because honestly, this piece
absolutely flips the script on
how we might typically think
about something like immigration
enforcement.
It really does.
So the core premise Abraham lays
out is, well, it's startling.
It's this idea that our forever
wars, you know, the ones
overseas, have in a sense, come
home.
Come home.
How so?
He argues that for decades, the
American economy has been, like,
deeply reliant on this huge
financial ecosystem built around
foreign conflict.
You know, logistics,
intelligence, private
contracting, all of that.
Sure.
The military industrial complex,
essentially, right?
But as he suggests, with a new
administration reportedly having
quote no appetite tight for new
foreign entanglements, this
whole financial model seems to
have just well found a new
engine right here at home.
And what's fascinating here, I
think, is Abraham's assertion
right off the bat, he says, and
this is a direct quote.
This is not a metaphor.
This is not a forecast.
It is a statement of present
reality.
Wow.
OK, so he's not pulling punches.
Not.
At all.
He argues that Trump, in his
view, isn't exporting democracy
or war anymore.
He's essentially imported the
war economy to domestic soil.
So the battlefields have
changed.
Completely, according to
Abraham, he writes the
battlefield is now Miami, the
war zone is Phoenix, the forward
operating bases are in Fresno,
Tulsa and Spartanburg.
And this whole process in his
framework means, quote,
deportation is the new
democratization.
That is quite the phrase, a
statement of present reality.
I mean, does he back that up
with hard data or is it more of
an interpretation of trends?
It seems to be more of a
macroscopic interpretation
connecting observed events
through this specific economic
lens.
He weaves together anecdotal
evidence, media reports and
economic observations rather
than presenting, say, large
quantitative data sets.
OK, so it's a framework for
understanding.
Exactly.
And he connects it to one of his
most striking claims, the
infinite horizon of this gold
rush.
He argues there's no treaty to
sign, no Hill to take, no
mission accomplished.
Meaning there's no end goal.
Precisely, he says achieving
some final objective is beside
the point.
What truly matters, in his
words, is the pursuit, the
machinery, the job creation and
the psychological buy in.
It's the process that's the
product.
Right.
OK, so we connect this to the
bigger picture then.
Abraham calls this a full
spectrum economic stimulus
masquerading as national
security.
Yes, and he says it works on 2
levels.
It creates work for the working
class and wealth for the owning
class.
He describes it as a bottomless
pit of domestic war
profiteering, shovel ready and
media proof.
It's almost unsettling how
neatly he frames it as this
economic fix.
It is, and it becomes even more
tangible when he gets into the
concrete examples.
Yeah, here's where it gets
really interesting.
He talks about this place called
Alligator Alcatraz, rising from
the Everglades in Florida, built
on an old Cold War airstrip,
apparently.
Right, and the details are quite
something.
He describes it as a
self-contained ecosystem of
detention.
Soft sided FEMA tents, biometric
scanning, perimeter drones, even
microwave crowd control weapons.
And it's not just tech.
He lists trauma therapists,
cooks, janitors, translators,
childcare consultants, religious
chaplains, legal compliance
officers, the whole 9 yards.
It's like a.
Small city built for detention.
Exactly.
And he really emphasizes that
the remoteness, the in
hospitality, that's the point.
It's meant to be a theater of
despair.
He calls it a warning made of
real estate.
And this taps into the
psychological aspect he
explores, too.
He mentions those whispers about
reopening Alcatraz in San
Francisco Bay.
Right, the actual Alcatraz.
Yeah, but he argues it's less
about, you know, actual
operational capacity and more
about what he calls
psychological velocity.
The idea?
Of the psychological velocity.
What does he mean by that?
He suggests the Rock doesn't
even need to house detainees.
It just has to haunt the
imagination to serve as the face
of mythic American resolve.
It's the symbolism that does the
work.
That's a fascinating take, the
physical structure as a
psychological tool.
So, OK, what does this all mean
for the economy then, for
people's jobs?
Abraham says Even with these big
symbolic sites, the real action
is in the contracts.
He asks pretty directly, who's
building this stuff?
Who's staffing it?
And he gives some pretty stark
examples.
He asserts things like Raytheon
isn't making cruise missiles for
Mosul anymore.
They're designing predictive
detention algorithms for Mesa.
OK.
And Ding Corpus and staffing
Kabul, They're staffing Kansas.
He outlines this huge range of
contracts, surveillance systems,
biometric tools, mobile data
vans, detention pods,
specialized IC training, AI
apprehension analytics.
So it's a massive redirection of
corporate and industrial effort,
according to.
Him, that's exactly the picture
he paints, A pivot from foreign
conflicts to domestic
enforcement.
And this redirection, Abraham
argues, hits differently
depending on where you are,
especially in what he calls Red
America's heartland.
He says there it's not framed as
cruelty, but as opportunity,
right?
He claims the towns gutted by
NAFTA, flooded with fentanyl and
hollowed out by
deindustrialization now see
detention centers rising like
new factories.
It's almost ironic, isn't it?
A security measure supposedly
filling the economic hole left
by lost manufacturing.
It is, and he gets very specific
about the jobs.
People who once worked the line
for General Motors are now
conducting intake interviews, he
writes.
Former coal miners, now Dr.
detainee transport buses.
Veterans who couldn't find work
are now drone techs monitoring
family units from 30,000 feet.
Wow, direct parallels.
Very direct.
And, he stresses, it pays.
It pays well.
And crucially, unlike war
abroad, it requires no moral
gymnastics.
This is America protecting
America, say the recruitment
ads.
So the messaging is key, yeah.
Now, politically, how does he
see this playing out?
He dismisses criticisms, right?
Whole fascist cosplay idea.
Yeah, he brushes that aside.
He calls it Quote Keynesianism
with guns and badges.
Meaning.
Like government spending
stimulating the economy, but
through enforcement.
And he even calls it a
decentralized WPA for the
culture war generation.
Like the New Deal jobs program,
but for today's cultural
battles.
That seems to be the implication
which leads him to this idea of
bipartisan immunity.
OK, what's that?
He basically argues that the
left can't meaningfully oppose
it without alienating working
class swing voters, and the
right sees it as moral
recompense for decades of
immigration betrayal.
So politically, it's sort of
locked in from his perspective.
Political trap, almost.
And he warns about its
permanence, doesn't he?
He does.
He emphasizes this is not
policy.
It is infrastructure.
It is political muscle memory.
And once entrenched, it will not
be easy to unwind.
That's.
Sobering political muscle
memory?
Yeah.
And he really double s down on
this idea of monetizing fear.
He says taxpayer dollars that
once went to rebuilding Mosul
sewers or wiring Kandahar's
power grid now goes to
reengineering deportation
logistics, mobile courtrooms,
AI, paralegal, Spanish language
facial recognition kiosks, even
morale maintaining internal
comms teams.
And his conclusion on that point
is stark.
We are not exporting American
values anymore.
We are consolidating American
fear and monetizing.
It monetizing fear.
So what Abraham seems to see as
the quote genius of this whole
boondoggle is that it has no end
state, right?
Exactly.
You can always deport more.
You can always refine the
dragnet.
You can always expand the
definitions of who is removable.
And crucially.
Crucially, he argues, the less
successful it is, the more you
can argue that you need more
money.
It feeds itself.
Perfectly, he calls it a self
licking ice cream bone of
enforcement, anxiety, profit and
populist dopamine.
That's quite an image, a self
perpetuating machine fueled by
its own perceived failures.
That's the core of his argument
about its structure, and when he
concludes the main discussion,
he's blunt about its
effectiveness as a system.
From his perspective, he just
says, in short, it works.
Works in what sense?
Works as this political and
economic engine he's described.
He suggests this is Trump's
magic trick.
No more trillion dollar wars
overseas, instead, a trillion
dollar war at home.
But.
Framed differently.
Right.
Not against Americans, but in
the name of them, he says.
It feels like security.
It smells like justice.
It sounds like recovery.
So wrapping this up for you, the
listener, Abraham ultimately
states that this whole thing is
what it has always been.
A gold rush, a Golden Corral and
a bottomless pit of American war
profiteering, now just closer to
home.
A powerful summary of his
thesis.
It really is.
So the question for you is why
should you care about this
specific interpretation of
immigration enforcement?
If this perspective that it's
fundamentally an economic driver
is accurate?
What are the implications?
What does it mean if this is
America's next economic engine?
Yeah, that's the core question,
isn't?
It and maybe a final thought to
leave you with what are the long
term societal impacts when
potentially a major economic
engine thrives on a process that
as the source suggests, has no
end state 1 rooted in anxiety
and the constant refinement of
enforcement and.
Maybe.
What does it mean for a society
when the pursuit itself, the
enforcement, the building, the
contracting, rather than any
kind of achievable resolution,
becomes the primary engine for
jobs, wealth, and even that
feeling of security and justice?
Something to think about.